[Applause]
you got the idea these are coffee table
books no one wanted I get it okay
like this one I can't believe no one
bought this a hundred and one things
Mike Pence considers adultery
check it out baby's reading a copy of
Good Housekeeping magazine Oh mother Oh
mother I shouldn't look at this one
right here licking a Harriet Tubman oh
yeah and then right down here watching
two tortoises have sad sinful he's got a
very low tolerance can't believe I
wanted taste yeah or good taste look at
this one this is a book no one wanted
cup stackers realizing they've wasted
their lives boy it's just dawning on
right now these are people that are just
realized no this is not something look
at this guy wow that guy's okay we got
Saturday he's fine yeah gonna be fine I
can't believe no one bought this one I
can't believe it
everyday objects wondering if they'll
ever end up in someone's body
[Applause]
that's the Peppermill right there now
this I happen to know from experience
and then this one down here that's gonna
take some world with yeah I like the
third one we've set this pattern the
third ones get gas yeah they like one
and two right third one a gas that's
what we call in the business
the bummer the third ones always a
bummer you pick the wrong again I think
Sid Caesar picked that alright good
reference the kids are going crazy yeah
check this one out can't believe no
one's snagged this one get well gifts
for people you kind of hope don't get
well yeah I guess check this one out
maybe it's your time over here and then
here's my favorite down here
heaven is nice I like it there just go
towards the light
this is a really weird one I can see why
it didn't sell but I find it fascinating
happy baby possums giving you the bad
news you failed your crap Eliezer look
at this one right here we're holding you
back here telling that kid and then down
here makes it any easier gets a baby
possum all right here's one man this is
check it out
mom's react to your last-minute CVS
Mother's Day present look at that right
there look at her face she's really
trying to we're trying to sell it oh
this is a good one
guess who's going commando and their
teams Burt yeah how do you know she's
not you know yeah we got right here
captain crime I always just back that my
favorite right there
please it's true I like the feeling of
freedom yeah
and finally dogs who can't believe you
just made a homophobic slur look at this
dog really really really in this day and
age look at this dog now you said what
this doesn't take oh no you didn't and
then this one's just less last guy is
really pissed
[Applause]
didn't sell but you bought them hi
[Applause]
you